the question should really be do i show
what to do as white
against the stafford i began working on
a study of like how to meet the stafford
i don't know if i want to show it yet
let's do a poll because some people
don't want me to show it
but others maybe do i don't know pull
because it's kind of like a secret right
where you don't want people to
start just refuting your opening that's
funny
so 85 yeah so 60
of the votes are saying yes
man 10 people indecisive saying maybe in
the future
i'm not going to show like a hard like
easy
refutation but i'll show i'll show
something fun
i'll show something which i think a lot
of people will appreciate
[Music]
don't let 80 people ruin the hopes and
dreams of thousands
but that's how government works right
or democracy wow so 1240 people have
hearted the study
more people heart this study than like
most of my instagram posts
maybe i should just focus on making
studies now
i'm tired but i feel like i owe chat i o
chat
something against the stafford so if
you're white
and you run into petrov also
i feel like i'm showing this to like
people
i'm showing this to an audience who
really enjoys playing the stafford
gambit
so if you enjoy playing stafford as
black
i think you'll enjoy this response as
white
what you can do is play bishop c4
and now it's reverse stafford gambit
and after takes you play knight c3 and
it's basically stafford county up at
tempo so you get the same
position potentially black goes into
this
where you have one extra move
uh now not every player will walk into
this not everyone takes on e4
but if they do uh
and they're kind of unprepared then
there's a very high likelihood they'll
fall for a trap in this position
um and we just like ask ourselves what
the most natural moves for black are
of course the pawns attacked the two
most natural moves look like
d6 and knight c6 both of which are
blunders
actually for the same reason too so we
can group these moves together both of
them
just lose to knight g5
so if we imagine let's start with with
d6
um defending the pawn looks like black's
trying to be solid
knight g5 likes winning my first born is
due in march so i do
hope you continue to stream so we can
both watch
oh that's awesome well
congratulations and happy early birth
happy early birthday to your firstborn
um okay so let me explain the reason why
white's winning here
because usually in the other like in the
reverse version
the knight would already be here and
there'd be this move and
you you would be slightly better but
without the knight here
if black wants to block with the bishop
we don't take with the knight we take
with the bishop and then we play queen
f3
and this is a double attack we don't
even like go after the pawn right away
we're threatening mate we're threatening
this
lacks in big trouble because if the
queen defends we just win the rook
oh is there 95
knight e5 might be playable actually
actually didn't look into this so the
idea of 95 is if takes we take if we win
the queen
i assume queen e7 though and
oh this is still winning wait oh 95 is
still winning for white
oh so there's two wins in this position
knight g5 is stronger though just
because of this queen f3 idea
uh but good job chat for also finding
this
um yeah and we can prove with engine
queen f3
the best try for black is to play this
sad move and then this and then this and
then this
and then knight f7 coming
[Music]
engine just tortures black with h4 and
saying black really has no moves
um okay so that's trap number one that's
g6
trap number two
uh we'll look at knight c6
and here again knight g5 and we're just
picking up the pawn
we can see what people do on the chess
um we have d5 we just take
and bishop e6 we take again
so really there's no good way to defend
the pawn
um i'm actually realizing that this trap
still exists
if so if queen e7 we saw this idea
earlier
27 we just take on f7 with the bishop
and again this idea is 96
pin and win only legal move is to take
and we take back
with the bishop maybe with a queen
um so what else
oh if this move does this also looks
kind of natural but again my g5
like there's so many ways for black to
allow knight g5 where it's just winning
and queen e7 again we see the same
pattern over and over
so there's some kind of yeah reminiscent
fried liver
ideas but this is an even better version
of fried liver
because black's severely underdeveloped
and has no good way to meet this
or meet defending the f7 pawn
um so very good question what should
black do in this situation
objectively the best move here is f6
which it's a difficult move to play if
you've never seen this before
but objectively it's actually
better for black it lacks well-prepared
um now there's kind of a crazy line
which i don't know if i want to get into
but after f6 white can play knight h4
and it's still
it's still complicated still very sharp
the idea of knight h was to play queen
h5
also if you play stafford as black let's
just go back
and look at normal stafford and white
plays f3
the move to play is knight h5 to
threaten this
um this isn't as good though
uh other other version we were looking
at
uh where is it f4 this is a slightly
better version
because white already has a bishop here
it's 4am why are you still awake i'm
sharing
i'm sharing even more opening
preparation because
you guys asked for it um
so we threatened this and really only
black has one move
to stop queen h5 which is g6
and then f4 and black has to be
very very precise here i think queen e7
is only move
i mean we can check the engine
okay maybe there's a few moves
but yeah f5
yeah like queen g7 is such a hard move
to find
even though it's kind of logical maybe
maybe it's not so hard
it's just such an awkward move to play
so even if black plays perfectly white
mike can still fight it's not losing
so anyway um people can dig in further
with the database with the um
with the engine as well if they're
curious about the slide
um so that's one recommendation if you
want to avoid the stafford entirely
and you play the staffer gambit yourself
go for bishop c4 and go for
a reverse stafford um and then
what black could do here so if black
plays knight c6
it's a two knights you could go for a
fried liver you could go for italian
you could go for this d4 line you can go
for nakmansen
d4 takes here takes in the knight c3
isn't that insane
you can check out jonathan trance or my
video
i think i only have one video and
jonathan has a
at least a handful of videos on that
vinson
um so yeah it just transposes into a
variation with many possibilities
now there's a question from sterling why
not
why not knight takes e5 after f6
um oh that's a good point yeah you
always want to be considering this idea
whenever black moves f pawn here
unfortunately
it's not winning it looks like you're
winning the rook
but you're not winning the rook because
queen e7
and your queen's pinned so
i don't recommend that some knight h4 is
the best uh
best try
um okay so hopefully this is useful to
some people
hopefully gives a an idea which
um some people have not seen before
oh one more thing one more idea just a
funny thing that people can do
i i know i've shown this a few times on
stream
but if uh if you take in black plays
here
and you don't want to go into stafford
gambit
you can play knight c3 and it's a
halloween
so now it's a white playing a dubious
opening
and it's black who i mean that's black
who can take and
um i mean life goes on but
it's funny that i can respond with uh
probably an even more dubious gambit
i actually don't know if halloween or
stafford is is more dubious
they're probably like a similar tier on
the dubious scale
yeah because the normal move order of
halloween
is like a four nights where white takes
here
so it's it's funny it's like a weird
transposition
where um yeah white plays this first
and then plays knight c3 and if flack
really wanted to but i can decline the
halloween
and insist on a stafford and play bishop
c5
after takes takes it's a stafford again
so i'm just trying to give people ideas
i hope i didn't crush any dreams by
by sharing too many secrets
anyway this will probably be a follow-up
video to
the already few videos i have on
stafford gambit on youtube
i'll have to figure out what to title it
i'm thinking i'm thinking i'll title it
if you enjoy the stafford gambit you
should try this opening
in this opening so at least bishop c4
and then knight takes e4 this has a name
it's a bowden
i don't even know
i don't want to hurt myself pronouncing
this but both in something something
gambit
so yeah basically just uh a similar
version
the cool russian guy asking what if the
knight just moves back
yeah so the halloween is dubious after
it takes d4
the whole point white grabs the center
if knight g6 we keep attacking
knight g8 we play bishop c4 i have a few
videos on this
anyway um yeah for people watching in
the future on youtube
uh hope you learned something uh if you
have questions
comment below or just post on reddit and
reddit can usually answer
and be sure to follow on twitch
and i'll see you in the future